let's remember that the jury foreperson
in Roger stones case yeah she had a
political bias she expressed publicly
against him tweeting about her hatred
for Trump supporters Trump and Roger
stone this is before the trial and now
we know premeditated fraud on the FISA
Court was even worse than we had been
telling you they knew all along it was
Russian information that was fed to
Christopher Steele from Russia knowing
it was being paid for by Hillary Clinton
meanwhile general Flynn's attorney
Sidney Powell now believes that new
evidence proves that Lieutenant General
Michael Flynn was set up and framed by
corrupt agents who withheld exculpatory
material she is now asking for this case
to be thrown out based on prosecutorial
misconduct here with more the co-author
of conviction machine standing up to the
federal prosecutorial abuse defense
attorney for the Lieutenant General
Michael Flynn former federal prosecutor
Sidney Powell all right we now saw with
Papadopoulos we saw with Roger stone
this is the miscarriage of justice
you've been talking about Brady material
you've been talking about exculpatory
evidence now we are told we are on the
verge of release of more documents that
will show general Flynn was innocent and
was completely set up and framed by the
upper echelon of the FBI that small
group of the highest-ranking members of
the FBI that deliberately set about from
at least August 15 2016 on to catch
general Flynn in something and either
prosecuting or getting fired that's what
we've alleged so long and it's proving
true with every new document disclosed
so you have the jury foreperson has a
direct bias I thought we had a right to
an impartial jury I must I must have
deluded myself exculpatory evidence
withheld and Papadopoulos case looks
like general Flynn's case looks like all
of it they knew all along that was
Russian disinformation and move forward
any everywhere can we expect that or
read into the hiring of more staff and
prosecutors by prosecutor Durham as
a sign that things are rent ratcheting
up for justice well it certainly looks
like he's on the right track and the
disclosure of these documents and the
advice that more are to come is going to
help from all angles it's the first step
toward restoring integrity and
credibility to the Department of Justice
and the FBI to have this information
exposed the US Attorney Assistant US
Attorney Joycelyn Ballentine assigned to
the case has advised us since Friday
that they're working to redact or redact
certain parts of the documents that were
filed under seal on Friday so that they
can be disclosed publicly either
tomorrow or Wednesday
it can't happen soon enough Roger stone
gonna go to jail on Thursday because he
scheduled a report for jail Thursday I
have no idea I would certainly hope not
I wouldn't think at the very least a
court would grant him a stay pending his
appeal there are serious issues in his
appeal well I will tell you this my
sources are telling me tonight Sydney
that in fact the Attorney General has
seen a lot of this and when I am told it
was breathtaking revelations and so
please keep us up to speed that man
served his country for 33 years 33 years
is this how we treated serve the country
he is absolutely innocent his plea was
coerced by lack of information and
threat to indict his son that shows in
the documents we filed on the public
docket Friday yeah and by the way he's
bankrupt Sydney Powell keep us up to
speed unbelievable